I mean it really is a comment on our age
the respect for marriage has now been so
seriously attenuated you actually have a
website if you want to commit adultery
it's like buying fish and chips online
it really is appalling but it's also
very naive I mean I would have thought
it was obvious right from the outset
that this would be vulnerable to hacking
because it's such a wonderful profitable
source of blackmail if nothing else and
of course people checking up on each
other
I really no wonder at the mentality of
people who've used this and believe
first of all that it's right to do so
secondly that it's safe to do so
how much sympathy do you have MS
Widdecombe with those who perhaps are
fretting today anxious that their
partner might learn about their
infidelity well I always have sympathy
with people who get themselves into
trouble but really they should have
thought about that when they decided to
use the website you can't say this is a
special sort of infidelity and that
therefore you have a special sympathy
with people who are going to be found
out in that way you might not if they
were going to be found out but by other
ways and in other means so infidelity is
infidelity whether it's achieved online
or in in other ways but yes I'm always
sympathetic where people have messed up
their lives and some people are about to
find that's what they've done
people are unfaithful for all sorts of
reasons and I just want to play this
clip to you if I may we spoke to one
member of the website who didn't want
her real name to be used
she joined to speak she says to people
online as she cares for her husband who
has Alzheimer's this is what she had to
say miss Whittington because I just went
on to it and it seemed quite innocent
really and until you sort of get on to
it I just felt so strongly when I heard
the news this morning but everybody said
to be tarred with the same brush it's
just one thing to break up relationships
and that is not this case
got to take that into account as well
haven't we I'm not exactly sure what
you're asking me to take into account as
I say it's poor woman he feels that she
her husband has got Alzheimer's and as a
result she went onto this website
because she wants somebody to talk to
and perhaps more than that she is in a
relationship that is declining and she
felt that that was the right way forward
for her do you have any sympathy for
that well as much sympathy as I would
have if she chosen to achieve the same
thing by other means there's nothing
about this site that suddenly makes it
moral to cheat on a partner no matter
what the circumstances driving that off
obviously we all know there are people
who are trapped in marriages like that
where they do care deeply for their
spouses but are no longer able to have a
normal marriage for whatever reason that
is no particular excuse for using this
sort of site I would have much more
sympathy with her if she had formed a
long-term relationship with somebody
that she'd known for ages and suddenly
found herself in there but she's quite
deliberately gone looking for this by
getting on that site so no I don't think
that you know excuses the entire site it
doesn't oh you're a hard woman aren't
you I'm not at all I've already said
I've got sympathy for people who messed
up their lives I understand the position
she's in but she's gone on this site
quite deliberately to do something that
most of us would say is wrong now you
know why would I have as I say any more
sympathy for that then I would for
somebody who had done the same thing
through other means and it is very cold
if you're going on this site you're
doing this deliberately it's not a
situation you fall into not a situation
you somehow don't want but find yourself
in and find yourself tempted to go
further it's not that at all from the
outset you know what you're going on
that site for so so those then who just
feel that they're going on the site for
a bit of privacy and to cheat on their
partner you have
absolutely no sympathy for them
whatsoever but as far as their details
subsequently perhaps being released into
the public forum you must have some
sympathy with that I've already answered
that question I've already said I've got
sympathy with people who for whatever
reason mess up their lives a lot of
people in are going to find that's what
they've done as a result of the release
of this information there is no morality
in hacking the site and releasing the
information there is no morality in
using the site for blackmail purposes no
morality in any of that but nor does the
morality and using the site and the
phosphors I'm guessing you would never
use one of those sites come on good to
talk to you as always and really cope
thank you very much to do for joining us
thank you